[Music]
can this article that uh that guys
handed me right before the show
they said you talked about it on your
show earlier it's probably worth talking
about the great resignation
yeah surveys are saying that
american workers up to 40 percent
of the workforce in america is looking
to change
jobs this year so here we are as we are
approaching
you know halfway through and there's
going hey i'm going to make a move
so you're going to see this in 2021 and
2022
a lot of people changing jobs you talk
about 25
is the low end of the survey 40 that's
an extraordinary number of people who
are saying you know what
it's time to make a change it's
certainly the panel brought on by the
pandemic giving you a philosophical
reset and saying
life's too short to work it's something
i hate with people i hate that's right
here's what happens
so we know that change is one of the
greatest concerns for any human being
change is scary
it has all this unknown and so change is
really really
ugly however when a forced change
happens to you so let's take the
pandemic
and it was a massive change for people
in largely
uh or i mean arguably the largest area
of their life you think about time you
spend at home
with family friends sleeping you think
about work that's the thing you spend
most time on your life and so when
there's a force change you didn't have
any
choice you were sent home either
furloughed laid off or you were working
from home
so now all of a sudden you're
confronting a change that you had no
choice over
and now you're dealing with that change
and so then we begin to go oh
wow this is huge what other parts of my
life would i like to change
and i think that's what has happened
collectively people are going
well i had to deal with this what would
it look like if i actually worked in a
place that i really loved what if i did
work
that mattered deeply to me what would i
have to do what if i change some things
to be able to get qualified to make more
money what if i paid off debt
and i think you're seeing people are
going you know what i think it's time i
think it's time and i'm going to move
here's what's interesting with this
40 of american workers are considering
moving into something else so they're
going to quit their current job
and you got 9.3 million jobs dave that
are open
right now and and so it is a good time
is the point because companies are
needing talent they want talent
yeah but if you're one of these
companies with no
soul you could take advantage of people
and no people aren't going to come no
that's true to end up with a labor
shortage
well we already have that absolutely i
mean you're going to end up not being
able because these folks are
what we're saying is is that because of
the pandemic they said life's too short
and that's what the surveys are
indicating um
that that they're not going to go to
work for a company
where life's too short again that's true
they're going to go
they want to do some plug into something
where they matter
where the work matters and where it's
something that they have actually have a
freaking talent at
that they're not just there to collect a
check that's right they have realized
like crucial driven organizations like
ramsey that's it
see we all along i think benefit from
this we will benefit from it i'm gonna
tell you this the ken coleman show
uh and ramsey solutions we're positioned
to help a lot of people make this move
because now they they need to know what
they're looking for some of them don't
know they're just going
this isn't it and so what we teach every
day as you know dave on the day
on the ken coleman show is hey you use
talent
as your tool your talent are premium
tools you do work you love we call that
passion
you just love the work and then that
work creates a result that matters
deeply to you so when we hire people
ramsey solutions
here's what you've got to be you got to
be a crusader you have to be
deeply deeply committed to the results
of hope
practical paths forward for people to
turn their life around whether it be on
the dr john delaney show
with your mental emotional health they
can't go turn your career around
uh or turn your money life around and so
when you come here you better be
missional and you better care about the
result of life change
hope practical steps forward for people
well you won't make it through the
interview process and if you did you
won't fit in
no if you lie to us if you want to just
collect you will be exposed because you
this is a different place
yeah well i mean we
we we were talking about that this
morning and staff meaning we this is how
we
do things and not everybody needs to be
a we that's true
you know so you mean if you if you want
to just
say well i've got a degree in x and so i
have a s
i have a talent yeah and you should just
pay me for delivering on that talent
yeah
nope yeah it's not going to happen nope
that's why we're getting so many
developers coming
oh yeah because develop we work a
developer uh 40 hours a week not 80.
that's right
and we work a developer uh where they're
writing code
doing something that matters and so when
they woke up during the pandemic they
didn't wake up and go i hate my job they
woke up and went man we've got a lot of
people need our help yeah
that's exactly right and so they're
going hey i know that
if i'm in here in this company coding
that it is going to be directly tied
to transformation see i think that's
that's what everybody wants is to make a
difference in this work
so the net result will be
for the economy overall if this
transition is accurate
if this survey is accurate will be a
huge
increase in productivity because people
will leave jobs
in bad situations that they are not good
at that they're not passionate about and
go plug into something
yes a that they're good at and b they're
passionate about in a better situation
and they'll produce more way more which
goods and services which will help the
economy overall
so really if people everyone followed
the ken coleman rule
and got in something where their talent
and their passion was aligned with what
they were doing every day
then the economy would boom even more
productivity rises
and durability increases people stay
longer
tenure people will stay in a place where
they go my
work matters the company sees me dave
you just touched on this
underneath all of this is a massive
warning to leaders
and to companies that if you don't give
people
a connection to their work if they can't
see that you care deeply about them
because they could be in their sweet
spot
talent passion mission aligned but if
you have a crappy culture
they will leave you they will leave you
and
and and you better have a place that uh
is
is healthy and you better have a place
that is dominated by leaders who care
for their people and people feel like
hey you see me i'm not just doing work
that matters to me but i matter to you
because you share how
we collectively everybody at ram
solutions matters to the world out there
that's what's special about this place
and companies that don't figure this out
you're going to lose talent
at an alarming rate and the companies
that figure this out dave
are going to explode they're going to
grow like crazy
yeah and one of the things that they
came to the conclusion i disagree with
was that
the worker is now demanding that they
work from home yeah
well those people are going to lose yeah
that's not going to work bad idea by the
way it's not going to work
yeah uh it hasn't worked you could try
all of the data
new is in that's right and work from
home doesn't equal work
no getting done can't have a great
culture
if everybody's separated all the time
yeah and it's we're seeing
major companies that thought they were
going to go that way swinging back now
again this is the third time we've gone
through this
watch this wave go back and forth and
i've been unpopular every time
because we don't work from home we work
from here with human beings
in the building where we can see each
other